of course absolutely honored times
that's amazing you know it feels good it
feels better now that you've said that
he's a great character isn't it he's mr.
first and he's so it's my job to turn up
on set and have as much fun as I can are
you a bit mischievous it's also your
birthday which many happy returns if you
could be a superhero which one would you
be
future Batman right here yeah I'm
wondering if when you're preparing for a
role if you're thinking does this one go
for the jugular or should I let this one
wash over me as you're approaching it
which approach do you like if I let
anything wash over me my life would be
much easier um I don't I can't explain
it I tend to I tend to go for the
jugular every time can everyone hear me
first of all is that great just the
first you know theatrical acoustics
stage train I I don't know how to do it
any other way actually and I don't know
that I bought I don't know that I've
ever been able to to do anything III say
it as a sort of because I'm aware that
it can be a strength but it can also be
a weakness because their focus is
obsessive and and so when I go for
something I go for it at the expense of
everything else and I I love what I do
simply and I I feel so lucky that I'm
allowed to do it and that I'd get to do
it for a living and and cinema and
theatre have had such a profound effect
on me
in my life and and so I always every
time a new script or a new role comes
along I am motivated by the thought that
I will I won't forgive myself if I don't
give it everything now you are a mega
superstar yeah and you must have a lot
of famous people on your contacts but
who is the most famous person you've got
on your phone oh my goodness that's an
amazing question I mean I've got all the
Avengers on my phone how's that that'll
do me
you're not Captain America everybody on
there Iron Man Hulk
Black Widow I'm nine nearly ten if I
could give you a time machine a magical
one say about any age in your life what
age would you go back to I love being 10
to be honest I remember when I was ten
years old my tenth birthday it snowed
and I took all my friends to the cinema
and we watched a film on the way back we
walked through the park and had an
enormous snowball fight no it doesn't it
snows on my birthday is getting pretty
cold 6th of March Oates very soon
fingers crossed
a white birthday bubble football for me
I'm doing we're gonna cross and bang
everybody out of the way so you getting
this big super bubble thing strap
yourself in and did a football and
you're banging each other so you hit you
falling over it it looks great I wish I
could do I've never done that well maybe
you should come well thanks for your
time Tom something you said really
struck me which was that about 10 years
ago you had the realization that life is
not a dress rehearsal that this was
really this is time to kind of get
serious I'm wondering what it was that
preceded that epiphany and how it's a
bird you on
[Music]
I think I had I've been very diligent in
my training and tried to listen to the
advice of all my teachers and
instructors as as a student as an
academic as a training actor and I
always wanted to do right by them and I
found myself is a very scary moment when
you're a young actor most people find
themselves in their early twenties and
everything is possible and nothing is
guaranteed and you start auditioning and
you if you're lucky enough you have an
agent and you start auditioning and they
send you everything from period drama to
casualty to Dairy Milk commercials yep I
went up for a Dairy Milk commercial when
I was born and and you are thrown into
the business and thrown into it at the
deep end and there's no time for doubt
or failure except routinely that's what
happens to all of us and I was so I
perhaps was too careful in auditioning
and I would always get close to to
landing roles and to booking jobs and I
would never quite get there and it's
it's a I mean that this is a universal
experience for all greater people
certainly actors is that the constant
rejection at the beginning and you had
to get used to it and you have to get
thick-skinned about it and I was she was
so exhausted by I was I trying to sort
of because at first you take it very
personally and I thought well no one's
like no one's gonna no one's gonna help
me get that the only person who could do
this is me and I started preparing in a
different way and and I sort of stepped
up to the plate a little better I think
because I could feel time sliding away
and and I wasn't getting on with life if
I just was sort of stuck in this rut of
neither acting nor doing anything else
and the experience of being in your
twenties is so energetic and I felt so
stagnant actually so I just kind of
changed everything up and and it worked
I'm lucky could do some let's hear it
because as I can't do the math oh that's
an easy one for me is it scottish
because my dad well when you've
obviously shave today oh gosh i don't
feel like that most the time
well thank you very much if you say so
it's good fun I love the job you know I
love acting it's a it's such a I'm so
lucky like get to do it and making films
and all that it's fun
I remember I was coming off a tour of
Cymbeline for cheek-by-jowl the theatre
company and we toured all over the world
but she came here in in May of 2007
right BAM right at BAM yeah and he'd
been to Moscow and Paris and wreak havoc
and Milan and Frankfurt and and then we
later did a stint at the Barbican and he
finished in Madrid and I remember I
would done six months of touring this
show and I was so tired and I all I
wanted to do was just chill and my agent
called me and said he got an audition
for a fellow next week but I knew he he
said Michael Grandage is directing it
Chiwetel Ejiofor was playing Othello you
and McGregor is playing the Iago and
Kelly Reilly is playing des
and I'd read this play at a level
English and I reread it and I knew for
some reason it for the first time how to
play Cassio and I didn't wanna leave
anything to chance
so I just learnt the entire part before
the audition and my audition took ten
minutes and michael grandage still
remembers that audition he said you came
in because I knew that everyone was
going up for that it was such an amazing
opportunity and fellows it was it was a
real moment as a very happy time it was
a great production principally because
of two Hotel was so magnificent in the
in the title role and he led from the
front and so many fortuitous things
happened as a result of that production
I remember we were all quite ready
that's very rarely we were we felt very
ready to go to open on our the day of
our dress rehearsal and we had the show
was ready to go with the last thing we
need
we nee actually needed an audience at
that point and michael grandage said to
the company would you mind if I opened
the house to people in their final year
at drama school so third year students
from Rada from lambda from central from
from the Drama Centre Amy were like no
not at all and it was a sort of nice way
of saying three tickets because they
couldn't probably working to get tickets
and then he said you mind if I ask my a
friend of mine called kenneth branagh to
come and see it
and so we all went you know like you
know the most sort of probably the - had
the greatest impact on the playing of
Shakespeare of his generation
and he knew michael grandage because
Michael before taking over the Donmar
Warehouse had directed can in Richard
the third at the Sheffield crucible
ambient a short you're fine yeah
absolutely
no worries and remember so Kenneth
Branagh came to the dress rehearsal and
he really enjoyed it and the next
morning I received a phone call from my
London agent saying Ken is doing a radio
play for the BBC of Cyrano de Bergerac
and he's played Cyrano and he would like
you to play Christian and so that's how
I met again and then the following year
Tom Stoppard also came to see a fellow
and he had written and the adaptation of
Chekhov's Yvonne off to be directed by
michael grandage in which kenneth
branagh was starring and they all turned
to me and said you have to play the
doctor so i was like okay and at the
same time the BBC's carthan director it
sent me the script for Wallander and I
remember embarrassingly in bashfully a
meeting
ken Branagh at the costume fitting and
he said so I'm calling this my
Hiddleston year and I just thought well
don't [ __ ] it up basically mercifully I
didn't so and then and then we became
firm friends and and that was and he
invited me to audition for Thor and it
was a very open net they were casting
they're both the Marvel wanted young
actors to play the principal roles who
had no previous attachment in the
audience's mind and I got cast as Loki
and that was really that was my foot in
the door so to speak what's been your
favorite TV program over the past year
oh that's a good question okay what can
I have to - okay so I loved as a series
called the night of with Riz Ahmed
which I watched in someone sitting and I
loved that and then I think probably
just maybe just pizza to the post was
some was blue planet to amazing
some of them a huge colorful in what
catfish doesn't look like a cat or
something else that's the best
description of a catfish I've ever heard
you should be the replaced David awesome
book it comes a theme of oh I thought we
were going for a fist bump are you doing
we should have a hundred sites yeah
thank you
yeah good luck and I'll see you again
[Music]
yeah yeah okay that's the deal all right
I was gonna ask a lot of people who have
a lot of actors who have a connection to
a character like that sometimes and they
come around again
you're something oh they almost think of
him as if he's like another guy like oh
that gets nice he's gonna be coming
around again that a nice guest in the
house is gonna be low-key he's gonna be
coming around you kind of have that
feeling that he's sort of like this
other guy at this other point yeah it's
so odd because you never it's so rare as
an actor to have a chance to go back to
a character sometimes you know
especially you create a character and
you hope that he makes an impact or
people find a connection people can
recognize something in him that's
entertaining or truthful and he never
very rarely did get a chance to go back
and I've gone back to him a couple of
times and his odd it's like hello
darkness my old friend you know yeah
we'll see we'll see nothing ends in the
Marvel Universe so the life of an actor
especially at the beginning feels
solitary and you're going up for
auditions and going off for different
parts and repeatedly are politely
declined
sometimes in politely declined often and
the door will be closed in your face and
you won't know why and that moment is
always a puzzling one because the
natural instinct is to take it
personally and often the decision isn't
personal
but you feel as though I certainly felt
as though I had failed and you can get
very despondent the challenge is to find
a way of negotiating that that sense of
rejection that sense of failure without
it eroding your sense of self and your
your own specific talent and your own
curiosity in the work I think it doesn't
matter what stage you're at in your
creative life or in your career but
people will always have an idea of
who they think you are and often it's
it's inaccurate or not wholly accurate
and he mustn't let them change your see
your own sense of who you are you have
to plow your own furrow because only you
know and only you know what you had to
go through to deliver that performance
in that audition or on that stage or in
that short film or film or television
series and protect that with everything
you have because all those people who
think they know who you are didn't do
the work and they don't know so have
have to have that faith in yourself
[Music]
you